welcome to this video the candidates
tournament is nearing its end we are on
round 12 today three rounds to go still
enter this video is about the game to
par love playing wide against Miller
playing black quickly the situation for
both players before the game to Paula
vism the minus 2 score being on last
place at the moment was spilled as on
fifty percent and still has at least
some theoretical chances to catch on and
he would need a window besides a the
final game that he will play against
Ireland he would probably need to win as
well so Swilley needs to get something
going maybe even in this game with black
let's see what happened to pile up with
e for he is varying a lot his opening
moves yet plate and English opening
against coyoacán yesterday and now we
got a sicilian spitless going for the
terminal variation which is not one of
his normal choices but he had played it
earlier at the tournament against
kayaking in the very first round I think
93 and now Queen c7 we should be three
asics we are following that game but not
a power plays Bishop to e2 more yeah
more strategically inclined move where
white is going to Castle short most
likely it's not a given but it's very
likely that this is so going to happen
yeah here blacks main move actually is
Knight f6 and after castles normal
choice black plays Bishop to b4 which is
giving this line its its own flavor it's
one of the rare lines and so the
Sicilian wait actually can develop your
Bishop to before and after that we get
entirely different positions were wide
very often placed with the move Knight
to a 4 um this didn't happen swidler
played another move we played the move
b5 which am i I it with some interest
because this is a line that I had played
myself quite a lot with black
in Nam yeah in the 1990s myth makes me
feel very old um I had played this quite
a lot it's an interesting way to play in
the Sicilian that it's not that is not
so overloaded with theoretical lines and
enforcing variations b5 is a typical
Sicilian move anyway and therefore if
it's in black zone general scheme of
things on what best move was what the
part of played the capture here on c6
and now sweedler decided to take with
the pawn and all ready yet spent some
some minutes and wonderful what exactly
IRA took some time for b5 interesting
yeah okay after the capture he took with
the pawn and this is not how I played it
so if I always had played Queen takes c6
back then it keeps us the typical
Sicilian structure life of course them
black is far behind in development this
is clear white has three minor pieces i
was already can even castle here but
like I'm well he has got some some
things going for him the good set up on
the diagonal and you get your stuff
developed as well Knight f6 Bishop e7
now it's not quickly going to open the
center so this is actually the the
normal move Queen takes c6 swidler took
with the pawn and I'm honest with you I
don't like this really um the problem is
that after this a for him the question
is what should like do now he decided to
push the porn relatively quickly and
it's not clear what else you should do
it could play Bishop to be seven but
you're falling behind in development so
much and also if you look at this what
happens here I hear what can even take
on b5 this is going to get very very
ugly
see takes yeah I also take black muster
probably play route to be a d8
intermediate move and yeah probably he
didn't like that so much it seems I'm
like a playable positioned out for black
as mentioned he pushed before and this
is a move that I personally would be
very reluctant to make simply because
the ensuing for instruction is so
convenient for white I'm going to put a
few more moves on the board to show the
structure this is what I mean white gets
this post on c4 for the night while
blacks bishop is always biting on this
granite like structure on e form and
also d5 is controlled by the pawn on d4
it's not so clear what black's pieces
are doing well why it has a very clearly
defined plan it's got this excellent
night on c4 and you will try to open up
the Queen side with means of c3 this
structure is very very one-sided I mean
like has has a solid position it's not
like he's going to go down quickly but
just look a couple of moves later which
is all very logical Bishop f4 provoked a
5 which was played by sidler Bishop g3
he must he must need to do that you
simply don't have a square for your
queen this is also not great and then
this is yeah also yeah well not great
you need to play if I for element and
now you even have this e 5 weakness so
white has various ideas to play on that
weakness like night here Bishop c4 925
and black does not have any clearly
defined counter play it is still as
mentioned a very solid structure this is
intending Bishop to g5 which also
happened quite quite soon yeah White has
played c3 this is clear you want to open
the queenside at some point and you in a
position where c3 is just giving you
more
option than black option than black ass
because what taking is normally out of
the question as it would weaken their
pawn structure even more young ROK t1
getting on the open file t8 and b3 I
think all this is very a very logical
play and the knots with Legos for Bishop
g5 activating this piece Bishop f2 and
night to f8 and really I really like
this idea for black he's trying to play
night to e6 and then after the sea porn
has moved in some way like capturing or
black maybe can capture then he will get
the defrost square for the night so this
is a good way to activate pieces I think
this was well played however now after
the capture to part of no took um
siviglia surprisingly went for C takes
d4 before i took with the sea porn now
think this lead lens black into really
really big trouble I mean before that is
just like I said it's it's not a very
convenient position why it is always
somewhat better but after this recapture
with the sea porn I think it gets very
serious for black I think you needed to
take with the a porn and the idea is
that in this structure you have the idea
to get the night to deform quite quickly
why it is still more comfortable let's
say after night be to for example you
can exchange those bishops and you you
have the more convenient for instruction
on light squares the good bishop now
it's it's somewhat somewhat nice of
white but black has some play you will
get the night to deform and this is
something I mean if white is somehow
obliged to take it oblige the wrong
world is some hour for storm um provoke
to take it then at least you get a pawn
pass on d4 this is I believe this more
comfortable for white but still am
rather playable position he took with
the sea por now
and now it gets very very difficult like
there's this movie should be six quite
simply and check this is no forced
otherwise you give a material yeah now
you don't really have a good square for
your queen now if I hanging as well so
you need to attend to that where do you
go with the Queen you go here you're
going to get hit with look d6 it's not
helping at all and yeah where else
frankly here I can just go here attack
on a five and take on e5 and I'm going
to win one of the pawns it's a it's not
nice at all he went to to be eight
multiple of just increase the pressure
further heap retreated back to f2 taking
on a five was not possible yet of course
after Bishop f5 Bishop c4 there is this
pain but this is just a strong move it
intends to play night to be six and
keeps the option of rope d5 in the
position after this yeah black is really
an in big big trouble you played Queen
to see seven maybe Bishop t8 also was a
tougher defense controlling v6 and
keeping an eye on the pawn it's still
very very nice for white afternoon t5
can try to defend like 96-94 and maybe
bishop to c7 but it's a very passive
defense let's say something like that he
can try to somewhat somewhat y am
setting up something like a defense of
waters everything covered it's very
defensive but still not like losing
immediately I understand that he didn't
want to play that so naive also was bit
down on time to part of us playing her
quite quite quickly he went Queen c7 now
after up to five yeah it's not
defensible
i'm on a five and a five played rook c8
and now h force play but Apollo I mean
quite amazingly spend ten minutes on
that and he didn't go for Roxy five
which is a very clean wind actually
queen is attacked and the next move I
just take that it's just the porn if I
for for nothing really well h4 it
probably also will win but Brooke c5 was
much simpler Queen d2 and there's still
the problem with the hanging pawns and
what should black movie cannot even move
the night because of rooty seven it's a
terribly a passive position the night is
the real problem that was given up by
this early before moose it gives up this
square the c-4 square form for the night
and this is basically the the source of
all the problems that black head in this
game um of course he could have defended
somewhat better but it's simply giving
up a bit too much early those squares on
the queenside yeah if defended with rook
th now or try to defend after Bishop b6
like of course needed to take Queen
takes Queen B 8 and now just Queen takes
f5 those pants are falling now yeah he
played on a couple of moves captured
here 26 but after the simple retreat
check and here King edge to black is
completely out of moves white will
simply go to d5 and then let the apron
run completely winning position and
swidler resigned yeah relatively yeah
simple game to watch really and also to
to do to do comments upon because well
this gave away lots of ground on the
queenside and it led to a very very
comfortable position for
white and which only could be defended
with absolutely precise play wish to
learn simply couldn't couldn't get on
the road I mean around here if you if
you take with the apron it's not exactly
brilliant but this is certainly a
position that black can try to defend
but this was giving a way of giving away
far far too much ground so for the
tournament this um has basically the
consequence thats villa is completely
out of the picture in terms of upsetting
aren't we pretty much regardless of what
he has played today are not speed Lance
no 1-1 the same as to Palo if they both
share not sure they share last place I
think minus one is is what what they all
have the bottom of the table is a very
very closer fields in this this
tournament um yeah Villa had a really up
and down tournament he's got good games
and wins and this kind of sometimes
pretty drastic losses certainly good for
the parlor to win a game again after
years suffered a lot in recent rounds
and played a fine game nothing to
criticize he always kept the pressure on
the only thing that he could have played
wuxi five to finish off things even
quicker but the witness a win is a win
at the end of the day all right quick
video but there is really not much else
to say this was a bit of an opening
inflicted trouble that he got himself in
and then he didn't defend a defend to
its best alright thanks for watching